what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and today we have
huge news about black widow after a ton
of talk from marvel studios and disney
about whether to keep black widow's may
release date and whether to keep it in
theaters or do it on disney plus they
have finally come to a decision
for starters they have moved the release
date to july
9th of this year and they have decided
to release black widow on disney plus
premier access as well as in the
theaters at the same time
this is great news because disney
actually came out and said that they
wanted to keep black widow
in the theaters they wanted it to
release in the theaters and disney plus
wasn't a real
option for them because they didn't want
to do that however it is very clear that
they reconsidered
after all right now we are in the middle
of a pandemic and although it looks like
it's getting a little bit better
all of the theaters aren't open yet and
the ones that are opening are only
opening at about 20 to 25
capacity and it looks like they just
didn't want to delay black widow
anymore than they already have so this
should be our last
and final delay july 9th is when black
widow will be coming out on disney plus
but you have to have premiere
access which means you're probably going
to have to pay an additional
20 to 30 dollars to watch the movie on
top of your monthly subscription to
disney plus
and again it is releasing in theaters at
the same time so for those of you
who have open movie theaters and feel
like going you still can
this decision seems to clearly be coming
after the success that mulan had on
disney plus premiere
seoul reya and the last dragon one
division and
recently the falcon and the winter
soldier became the most watched
disney plus premiere ever to date on top
of the mandalorian on top of one
division it beat them both
so it seems like we have these past
projects to thank because we are finally
getting black widow
on disney plus premiere access and in
theaters
it had been back and forth for a while
now and we have been talking about it
for
pretty much a year at this point but
this is pretty much the best case
scenario you can watch it on disney plus
premiere access if the theaters aren't
open or you don't feel safe
enough going to the movie theaters or if
you do want to go you can go
this is the best of both worlds and
either way black widow is finally coming
out so let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below let me know if
you're going to see it in theaters or if
you're going to be buying it on disney
plus premiere access don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest marvel news don't forget to like
the video and for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof
me